you need can work harder you need and
discipline your mind better we need to
help people more than just saying it's
okay it's okay that you're not willing
to help your help yourself that's not
okay it's not okay it's not acceptable
even though it's your life if that's
acceptable that's unacceptable
and there's a lot of people in this
world me included that if I accepted
that I wouldn't be anywhere so yeah a
lot of people just they they start
creating a narrative about themselves
that make it okay the ultimate get out
jail free card and now the world is set
up to have so many GI Joe free cards
number one you've got to work on
yourself it's very important that you
engage in an ongoing process to develop
you spend more time on yourself than
what you've been spending
it's very important you owe that to
yourself you'll get scared sometimes
your mind will go blank on you some
people you will allow to unnerve you and
you'll wonder what's wrong with me I'm
not crazy that's why you've got to learn
to make a conscious delivery determined
effort to stand up inside yourself
working on yourself watching that inner
dialogue it will determine the quality
of your life
I don't believe this I know this
happiness for most people is temporary
so success without fulfillment that's
called failure do you know somebody
who's got everything they thought they
wanted and they're not fulfilled they
got a real problem so what's going to
make you fulfilled finding your gift
contribution life's not about me it's
about we if we feel like we're
contributing to someone else then we
don't just get something we become
something and what you get never makes
you happy long term who you become makes
you very happy or very sad so part of
that art fulfillment is what's my
contribution the second part of it is
appreciation some of you are
contributing but you're not taking the
time to really appreciate you're not
noticing every moment of your life you
got to decide what are you going to
focus on and what does it mean and what
are you going to do is it the end of the
beginning are you being punished
rewarded meaning because we're all life
is shaped and you have the power to
change the meaning how fast you better
ask a better question I'll come up with
a better answer
but education is not the most important
thing in your life I'm sorry it's not
your dream is the most important thing
in this world it tops your education the
principle came up on the stage for our
speaker don't ever say that to my school
again well I'm just telling you Don you
can save your kids a lot of pain if you
ever talk to them about their dreams you
got to talk to young people about their
dreams see it's not your education the
Bible don't even mention education it
ain't even in there Harvard ain't in
there UCLA ain't in there the Bible says
a man without a dream or Vision should
perish if you talk to kids about their
dreams your dreams can spur you to get
the education but if you never find out
what a child is dreaming about you can't
hold their attention
so if you want to make six figures you
can't just be talking about you want to
make six figures you hear what I'm
saying to you tonight if you do the
three things I tell you to do tonight I
guarantee you whatever it is you want to
do in life you'll be able to do you will
be able to accomplish whatever you want
to academically financially relationally
whatever so three things all right I'm
gonna tell you the story I gotta get out
of here there was a young man who you
know he wanted to make a lot of money
and so he went to this Guru right he
told the guru you know I want to be on
the same level you on and so the guru
said if you want to be on the same level
I'm on I'll meet you tomorrow at the
beach at 4am he like the beach I said I
want to make money I don't want to swim
Guru said if you want to make money I'll
meet you tomorrow 4 a.m so the young man
got there at 4am he already rock and
roll got on the suit the old man grabs
his hand said how bad you want to be
successful he said real bad he said walk
on out in the water so he walks out into
the water watch this when he walks onto
the water it goes Waist Deep so he like
this guy crazy he's like I want to make
money he got me out here swimming I
didn't ask to be a lifeguard I want to
make money he got me in so he said come
on a little further walked out a little
further then he had it right around in
this area
stole the area so this old man crazy
he's making money but he crazy
said come on out a little further came
out a little further it was right at his
mouth my man like I'm about to go back
in here this God Is Mine
but old man said I thought you said you
wanted to be successful he said I do he
said walk a little further he came
dropped his head in he had him held down
just before my man was about to pass out
he raised him up he said I got a
question for you somebody answered the
question for me he said when you were
underwater what did you want to do I
said I wanted to breathe
he told the guy he said when you want to
succeed as bad as you want to breathe
then you'll be successful I don't know
how many y'all got ass man here today
but have you ever had an asthma attack
before you short of breath SOB shortness
of breath you wheezing
the only thing you're trying to do is
get some air you don't care about no
basketball game
you don't care what's on TV you don't
care about nobody calling you you don't
care about a party the only thing you
care about when you're trying to breathe
is to get some fresh air that's it
and when you get to the point where all
you want to do is be successful as bad
as you want to breathe then you'll be
successful and I'm here to tell you
number one that most of you say you want
to be successful but you don't want it
bad you just kind of want it you don't
want it better than you want to party
you don't want it as much as you want to
be cool you most of you don't want
success as much as you want to sleep
someone you love sleep more than you
love success and I'm here to tell you
today if you're going to be successful
you've got to be willing to give up
sleep
you got to be willing to work off for
three hours of sleep two hours if you
really want to be successful some days
you're gonna have to stay up three days
in a row
because if you go to sleep you might
miss the opportunity to be successful
that's how bad you gotta want it listen
to me you gotta want to be successful so
bad that you forget to eat Beyonce said
once she was on the set doing her thing
three days had gone by she forgot she
didn't eat
because she was engaged I never forget
uh when 50 Cent was doing his movie I
did a little research on 50 and 50 said
that when he wasn't doing the movie he
was doing the soundtrack and they said
when do you sleep 50 sleep he said sleep
sleep is for those people who are broke
I don't sleep
said I got an opportunity to make a
dream become a reality what helps me is
to keep the hard times and in front of
my mind this allows me to go into these
big moments that I've worked my ass off
and you guys have broke your ass off it
allows me to go into these big moments
with a different perspective
what it also does for me and again this
just this is what works for me
I keep my back is up against this
every day
it's against the wall but it's up
against us because it's what I believe
in and when my back is against us
then there's nowhere to go
but that way so I feel like this could
be something an ideology mindset that
could help you
could
if you look at it that way
because you made it already we made it
we're successful boys and we're lucky
boys to be where we're at oh you guys
made it everybody's rich in the room
nobody's gonna get evicted anymore
anything you've got there's no more
money problems right you got a lot of
hands out now I think a little bit can I
get a little bit right that happens but
when you make it
for me I need this
I need this so every day my back is up
against us
and this is how I operate
now doesn't mean you don't smile doesn't
mean a laughing joke
right happy I'm happy I'm a happy guy
but when it comes to business when it
comes to executing
it's up against this
and I got to go that way
and I'll give who is in front of me
they're not going to stop me